[Music]
in age is just a number news hey that's
not bad that's so true though age is a
number submitted by ready for the
weekend every day's a weekend for me mhm
age is a number but then like if you
want to live in a civilized society
where there's no molestation then it's
not really just a number cuz you go to
jail six years after a Chinese pop star
declared his love for a 12 year old they
are now getting married but it's a China
coz he's legal no he's 18 yeah how old
was the the person that person that was
a pop star 16 he was 24 years old when
he declared his love for this 12 year
old that's where he met when she was 8
years old because he was hit her music
teacher he was oh boy and he watched her
grow up yeah any girl watch grow up a
mother don't you
it's kind of weird like there definitely
is like something mentally we it's it
weird you know to me cuz I really wish I
knew what that felt like which I thought
I had like if there were like pedophile
glasses I wish I could put that [ __ ] on
I want to understand like what's so
delicious about an 8 year old
oh okay so you're not saying like I
desire that yeah I'm like that's a
[ __ ] Katie crazy [ __ ] but for
them not mmm it's like a [ __ ] fresh
muffin out of the oven it's not even
when I see a kid I think like you smell
like backpacks wet and asphalt when I
see children
I see flies going around them and [ __ ]
[ __ ] melted butter on a [ __ ] garlic
toast cuz you could even see like like
like little girls right you're like one
day she's gonna be pretty but as of
right now you're [ __ ] hideous yeah
you know one day when you grow up you
might be a beautiful woman mm-hmm
you know but yeah right now you're still
picking her nose yeah it's just like you
just girl you think 3 me I I can't I
can't answer obviously he's not a
pedophile but for someone that's 12
right for someone that's uh I fell in
love when she was 8 though
they let went you know that yeah okay so
I think he liked her at 12 maybe around
that age um kids are more impressionable
so like maybe she was just like super
excited to see her friend and like oh
hey it's you
oh and then maybe that's what got him
excited yeah maybe it's less of like
maybe he doesn't factor in the 12 year
old thing he may be he's do yeah I know
right dude I don't even know how to wrap
my brain around it outside of that like
it maybe it's like what if he's just
like a really ugly lonely dude and he
confused the excitement of a child for
life yeah but he's a pop star he's just
a straight-up pedophile yeah yeah he's
[ __ ] up I was thinking the same thing
like you're a loser you get no attention
from women
you're a [ __ ] tutor or something and
then finally maybe because he's a pop
star he can't get it all the time that
he thinks they're just using him for
that pure love these are the Chinese are
Kelly
yeah because I'll tell you like the leo
and she was like 15 or 16 yeah well I
know also like Chinese it's a little bit
it's not as advanced like they're not as
like sexual and [ __ ] as like we are over
here also two [ __ ] 15 year-olds you
see the [ __ ] government [ __ ] hell
yeah we said the stupidest [ __ ] [ __ ]
but we thought we were hella smart
yeah I can't stand that like you know
what's like being a grown-up shut up 14
year old you shut the [ __ ] up what are
you sixth grade yeah 12 is like mad
corny like I can't even man and like
you're like top-heavy I still got a
little bit of baby fat and why you're
[ __ ] we can't even go shopping
together cuz he's like I'm gonna go to
the kids section real quick it's just
weird you can stop like you guys are
having like a dinner conversation right
and you're like dude what's going on
dude [ __ ] taxes are coming up you go
what's wrong with you
I got stuck some SATs and [ __ ] you know
it's like even that still older like
dude will you do it my start testing
it's like [ __ ] man I gotta do the V sit
and reach tomorrow
oh [ __ ] in the recent past man I can't
touch my toes yet like it's hard it's
not like a Brazilian 12 year old we're
talking about we're talking about a
Chinese 12 year old which means they
look like the three oh we got a picture
well he looks really young you know they
look like brother and sister on the
laughs man God dude this picture of her
she looks like a [ __ ] toddler I think
she was 12 that is not Devin T now cuz
she's born in Canada okay it's not even
legal yet for them to get married in
China they look the same age on the
right that's crazy oh my god thank you
lady that they're gonna probably go to
Canada for them to get married because
that one should they look more the same
age on the right like baked baby like
they could be a couple my 31 yeah [ __ ]
let me aging really well see that's what
I mean like I wish whatever eyeball
lenses he had on the left I wish I could
put that on to understand I think you
might be viewing it very sexually too
then
no not just sexually I don't know what
does he feel like as well so far you've
referred to it as delicious and a
buttered muffin yeah saying that leads
me to believe that it's because it's
know so for example just use the right
words you know it's a for example like
when you see like some cultures right
and they eat some crazy [ __ ] oh yeah
lunar or [ __ ] maggots or whatever and
when you see them eating it it looks
like they're eating like a Dodger dog
because you're referring to it very
sexually something for him it might not
be sexually emotionally appetizing like
whatever it is yeah that's what I'm
saying so then for me that's why I
brought in my point of saying because
she's more like she has more youth sir
she's not jaded like [ __ ] someone
that's older that she might be more like
yeah here's my friend here isn't so I
want to see that I want to see how she
swept him off his feet that's what I
want to see even that but you felt
because if I look at this never felt
that before from
just in general cilantro brush that's
all time but so I want to see how a
twelve-year can do that to me I like a
little realism in my women though like I
don't like that [ __ ] like frou-frou
everything's perfect type of attitude
[ __ ] annoys the [ __ ] out of me is like
when shits bad it's okay to say it's bad
but they're like shut the [ __ ] up life
sucks sometimes [ __ ] you'll be there
with me connect yeah I think it's very
difficult for me to watch someone grow
up into a woman and then still see them
as that I could be involved with yeah
that's me every single like girl that I
know like that I grew up with or
whatever they're far beyond friendzone
they're just like you're my grandma
we're the same age but you're my grandma
I will never like get involved with you
romantically or anything it's even like
even like with like kids that are like
young boys write to you in there in my
mind there's still that little kid and I
still want to Punk them and [ __ ] pass
them to throw them in a river you know
what I mean but but they're like 25 now
and I just look at them so true all of
you when I met you at the city you're
the same age that I met you yeah like
Julia she's still like a little baby
you're stuck at that age nice I don't
know 22 23 anyone yeah oh thing here so
he has 1.4 million followers followers
on wait we both that's quite a low last
number over there if you got billions of
people there's like a thousand followers
relative and then Mickey has 1.8 million
who's Mickey the girl the girl why does
she have so much does she have pop star
to she's a model and apparently she
sings too we had like a group to go with
the two of them they joined forces and
they were making music together we found
love when I was her piano teacher when
she was 12 and he was 24 he commented on
rivo I simply cannot wait for the next
fourth birthday's to pass he was
counting down each one and that's when
he like declared his love for birthdays
at was she's 16 I was confused about
this year
not the right math but I don't know so
then now the reason why they're making
headlines is because on the same site
they ended up posting she posted or he
posted a photo of someone like in a
wedding dress and then it he's added we
are indeed preparing for our wedding in
all kinds of ways on September 11 2008
team Nikki will turn 18 and it will be
ten years since we first met and so
that's when I just like blew up and went
hella viral like holy [ __ ] everyone like
now they're gonna get married and now is
this is just really big news and a lot
of people are speculating that it's like
really pedophile II or some people happy
about it or are they there's a lot of
people that are relieved like happy and
that they're saying like oh it's true
love like they found in each other
it is the fence they did last a very
long time like he didn't cheat on her
with another twelve-year-old like
elementary school with like whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa well well well what do we
have here hello unicorn backpack say no
I'm real disappointed in him because he
was kind of fine and I felt like he
could I felt like he could do a little
better than a twelve-year-old a little
better a little older
Oh
that's brother and sister right no he
loves all this [ __ ] now dude
oh my these brief I can't do it I can't
he's a good-looking guy she's cute but
it's good look you guys a good-looking
guy don't show me that that's great my
brother and sister dude but like that's
my thing like he's gotta be a pedophile
because he's a very attractive he's a
loyal pedophile though the faithful
pedophile
according to her they've kept their
relationship yours this is her statement
after it went viral a little [ __ ] no
[ __ ] I believe that yeah she said I
do want to correct something there are
people who are changing our story and
are using the fact that I was eight
years old when we met and in doing so
are harming us and our loved ones in
their articles they're deleting the part
that really matters when I was 8 I met
Mui and he was my music teacher teaching
me how to sing and teaching me
self-confidence by the time I was 12 my
parents had let me read many books and
see many movies and I had good education
at school many of my friends with the
same age as me had started reaching
puberty and I'll and also started and I
also started to think about who I liked
I could talk to Maria about everything
he said that when I would reach the age
of dating he would help me check them
out at the time I did not understand
what it meant and he said he would not
let me date bad guys because it is very
easy oh that sounds like every Korean
pervert out there dude at a church
looking back now Korean young parrot
looking back now he was also still young
at the tall young he's 24 12 years
younger older than her oh my god told
him that if he did not want me to get
hurt in the future he should just marry
me at the time we were just joking
around like playing house [ __ ] jokes I
got 12 year old said that to me at 24 I
would [ __ ] slap her marriage is not a
joke it's like seriously and then I
would tell her parents Amy do you know
what your freak of a [ __ ] daughter
said to me with that uncomplicated
promise I grew up with him by my side of
course we will stay pure until marriage
what they left out the whole grooming
part is the most awkward I just pictured
him like teaching her piano da da da da
why don't you just marry me
leave
yeah I'd leave that room immediately
it's like hey there's one person that
commented I don't think this is as
serious as pedophilia the goal of
pedophilia is unpure sex no it's not but
they have been together a long time
thing has no evil intention what do you
mean by pure and impure sex like so they
haven't had sex what they're saying yeah
then you haven't taken their
relationship or it's gonna happen when
she looks like a woman yeah I don't know
man that's just [ __ ] weird cuz it's
like at that age are so impressionable
of course he's gonna follow with the
older guy that's always their net and
he's good-looking yeah yeah you know
come on now yeah there's this sexologist
Chinese sexologist I said that the three
principles of sex is that it's voluntary
between adults and in private if this is
in line with these three principles and
it isn't it is not punishable by law the
law can't punish adults who have sex
with girls in the age of 14 but if they
wait with having sex until they are both
adults in the law cannot control them so
everywhere under 14 you can punish
adults who have had sex with girls under
age 14 oh so I guess the laws out
there's different Wow
well they do what they do it's not it's
not my land not my country not my loss
oh what a little weird that's offer for
my human taste
[Music]